[Musique]
on s'active au musée léon dierx en
attendant l'exposition de manet à
picasso le musée qui s'apparente plus à
un atelier où chaque artisan rôles
précis à jouer d'ici quelques jours ici
seront présentées des oeuvres d'une
valeur inestimable
les galeries d'exposition se sont refait
une beauté pour accueillir comme il se
doit l'art de la fin du 19e siècle ça
fait un petit bout de temps qu'ils
travaillent déjà il a fallu préparer des
oeuvres c'est à dire qu'il faut les
sortir de leur conditionnement tout au
long de ces années les mettre sous cadre
et puis aujourd'hui on procède au début
de l'accrochage avec une partie des
oeuvres puisque toutes ne sont pas
encore arrivés place et les oeuvres au
sol pour à peu près les réunir là où
elles doivent être définitivement
ensuite on fait tout simplement comme on
fait chez soi des trous dans les murs où
il faut les centres et
les pauses et les sécuriser et ensuite
on procédera à leur éclairage adéquat le
moment venu de la peinture des murs à
l'accrochage des oeuvres provenant du
fonds du musée léon dierx cette
exposition a nécessité plusieurs années
de préparation
il s'agit à la fois de mettre en valeur
dans des espaces qui ont été pensés en
fonction des oeuvres bien évidemment qui
vont être exposés des espaces qui met en
valeur les aigles sans les écraser non
plus puisque le évidemment le sujet
précis le principal c'est ce que l'on
présente et non le support donc c'est ça
aide à la lecture puisque ce sont des
espaces compte des limites ainsi et qui
apportent quelque chose d'un peu
dynamique dans ce parcours le choix des
couleurs pour les murs est bien sûr
important dans cette scénographie mais
ce qui reste primordiale et bien sûr la
protection de ses tableaux et leur bonne
conservation à température ambiante doit
donc être contrôlés au degré près parce
qu'il ya deux éléments c'est la
température certes mais c'est surtout la
halle à l'humidité l'humidité qui
contenue dans l'air qui qui fait qu'
elles peuvent endommager les oeuvres et
donc c'est un sans cesse un équilibre
entre le température et le et le on
dirait l'humidité la température
participent à cet équilibre en attendant
les offres sont placés au sol avec une
reproduction de l'original un nombre
précis où elles seront accrochées pour
être admiré et puis pour les estampes
puisque ça va être une grosse part des
oeuvres présentées pendant cette
exposition il faut savoir que la lumière
est un est un ennemi de la conservation
et donc il faut l'éclairage pendant
l'exposition évidemment mesurer et le
temps d'exposition va l'être également
c'est à dire qu'elles vont être exposés
pendant près de six mois il faudra les
mettre à l'ombre pendant quelques années
suivantes pour en tout cas
protéger
ses avants
cette exposition qui croise les estampes
de la douane ainsi pour art gallery à
ceux du musée léon dierx a nécessité
plusieurs années de préparation
il a fallu choisir les oeuvres poncet
l'itinéraire organisé la venue des
estampes d'afrique du sud tout un
parcours mené par bernard leveneur le
directeur du musée léon dierx cette
exposition lidén est très simplement
c'est qu'on avait organisé en 2013 une
exposition dans le cas des années de
l'année de l'afrique du sud en france et
des contacts avaient été pris avec la
donne et ce bond art gallery qui est un
grand musée qui est un serveur
johannesburg la capitale économique de
l'afrique du sud qui est un musée qui
est né au même moment au musée léon
dierx il a ouvert ses portes en 1911
nous on enverra également nos portes en
1911 et quand on a commencé à établir
les premiers contacts avec la direction
scientifique de la jeunesse galerie moi
je suis allé là bas et on a commencé à
regarder mais je me suis très vite rendu
compte que finalement il y avait une
complémentarité entre ce que nous avions
ici à la fois dans les collections
initial plus la fameuse donation vollard
est ce que l'afrique du sud avait
constitué dès leur création en 1911
puisse plus tout ce qu'ils avaient
racheté en fait par la suite il reste
encore du travail beaucoup de travail
l'exposition de manet à picasso commence
à prendre fin
[Musique]